this year we have carried some of the
highest participation in the history of
Carnegie Mellon's engagement at the
World Economic Forum and Carnegie Mellon
University faculty and staff there are
nearly 12 of them here they are
connecting with industry leaders from
around the world to give their
perspectives on critical issues facing
the world whether its climate change
cybersecurity or terrorism that
intersection of Technology and human
condition couldn't be more relevant and
this is where Carnegie Mellon University
really shines as we head back to the
campus after a very exciting week here
at the World Economic Forum we are
energized by the possibilities and
especially by the impact that our work
can have not only in the US but around
the globe